[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده فالوقت الذي احدثكم
في احداث تقع وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصور من
تل ابيب الان ومشهد الاحتجاجات المتصاعده
والتي بدات تلقي بظلالها على حكومه
نتنياهو خصوصا بعد قراره اقاله وزير دفاعه
المكرمه اجواء الحرم المكي في رمضان بعيده
انتهاء صلاه التراويح هناك
ولا ينظر اليهم يوم القيامه ولا يزكيهم
ولهم عذاب
في موضع الحصاد
ازمه تعديلات قانون القضاء تهدد حكومه
نتنياهو بعد مطالبه من وزير الامن الداخلي
بن جفير يتنياهو يقيل وزير دفاعه يقف قلند
اثره تصريحاته المتعلقه بالاصلاحات
القضائيه ويتعهد بالتصدي بقوه لعصيان
الاوامر العسكريه
يصف الاقاله بانها تهديد لان اسرائيل
ومسؤولون امنيون يحذرون من تاثير الازمه
على جوزيه في التعامل مع التطورات الامنيه
السلاح النووي التكتيكي ومخاوف حافه
الهاويه بعد اعلان روسيا نيتها نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا واشنطن تقول
انها لم ترصد عمليات النقل وانها ملتزمه
بدفاع المشترك عن حلفائها والاتحاد
الاوروبي يصف الخطوه بانها تهديد للامن
الاوروبي ويتوعد من بالعقوبات
على بعد 200 كم جنوبيه موسكو وسيره
اوكرانيه محمله بالمتفجرات تسقط في مقاطعه
روسيه والقوات الروسيه تقول انها عطلت
نظام الملاحه في المسيره وعلى الارض
الاوكرانيه ميليشيا فاغنر تعلن السيطره
على مصنع تتحصن فيه قوه اوكرانيه في ضخمه
والقوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها تمكنت من صد
عشرات محاولات الاختراق في الايمان وبخمت
في السودان بدء مناقشه ملف الاصلاح الامني
اخر الملفات الممهده للمرحله الانتقاليه
نقاش بشان عمليات دمج الدعم السريع
والحركات المسلحه في الجيش
يصفها بالمهمه الصعبه ويقول انها لا ينبغي
ان تخضع لاي اجنده سياسيه والبرهان يقول
انه على القوات المسلحه ان تاتمر لسلطه
مدنيه منتخبة والا تدعم حكومات ديكتاتوريه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا انعكاس الاحتجاجات ضد
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو على ائتلافه
الحكومي فبعد مطالبه من وزير الامن
الداخلي اقال نتنياهو وزير الدفاع يوقف
تاتي هذه التطورات مع تحذيرات مستمره من
مسؤولين امنيين من شرخ قد يصيب الجيش
والامن جراء الازمه باستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
الى اي مدى قد تؤثر هذه الازمه على تعامل
اسرائيل الامني في الاراضي المحتله
وخارجها
25% قالوا ان الازمه ستؤدي الى اضعاف
قدرتها ايضا 25% من الاصوات توقعت انها لن
تؤثر اما الخمسون في المئه المتبقيه
فقالوا ان اسرائيل ستسعى لاستخدام التصعيد
للهروب من الازمه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
هذه كانت اطلالتنا على وسائل التواصل بشان
هذا الملف اما بشان اخر التفاصيل فما
زالتفاعلات اقاله وزير الدفاع يقف قلن
تتلاحق ففي اول تعليق له قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو انه سيتصدى
بقوه لعصيان الاوامر العسكريه وكان
نتنياهو اقاله وزير دفاعه بعد يوم من
مطالبه وزير الامن الداخلي بذلك بعد رفضه
دعم التعديلات القضائيه واوردت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان نتنياهو ابلغ جالنت
انه فقد الثقه فيه لانه يعمل ضد الائتلاف
الحاكم واتهمه بتقويض جهود التوصل الى حل
نتنياهو كان ارجا اجتماعا طارئا كان مقررا
اليوم مع رؤساء احزاب الائتلاف الحاكم الى
يوم غد الاثنين في الاثناء تعقد لجنه
الدستور التابعه للكنيست الاسرائيلي خلال
الاسبوع الجاري جلسه استثنائيه لاعداد احد
قوانين التغييرات القضائيه المتعلق بتغيير
تركيبه لجنه تعيين القضاه للتصويت عليه في
قراءتين ثانيه وثالثه
وساعات بعد الاعلان عن اقاله وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي دعا منظموا الاحتجاجات
المناهضه للتعديلات القضائيه للتظاهر امام
مقر وزاره الامن في تل ابيب وتزامن هذا مع
اغلاق متظاهرين اسرائيليين شارع ايلون
الذي يربط كل الطرق السريعه الرئيسيه
المؤديه الى تل ابيب فيما يواصل المحتجون
التجمع في وسط تل ابيب رافعين شعارات
رافضه لتعديلات قانون القضاء ولاقاله وزير
الدفاع
[موسيقى]
هذه اذا صور مباشره لهذه التجمعات
والاحتجاجات على قرارات نتنياهو للتعديلات
القضائيه طبعا هذه الاحتجاجات مستمره منذ
اسابيع
[موسيقى]
من القدس تنضم الينا مراسه الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان اطلعينا اولا على ابرز ردود
الفعل حتى الساعه على قرار نتنياهو اقاله
وزير دفاعي
يعني جلال لو اردنا ان نتحدث عن ردود
الفعل ربما رد الفعل الاقوى حاليا في
اسرائيل هو ما يحدث في الشوارع
الاسرائيليه في غالبيه المدن في تل ابيب
في القدس في مفارق طرق رئيسيه ومحاور طرق
تربط بين المدن الاسرائيليه في داخل الخط
الاخضر هناك الالاف ممن خرجوا في تظاهرات
عشوائيه دعت اليها او دعا اليها منظموا
الاحتجاجات التي شهدناها منذ بدايه هذا
العام احتجاجا على التغييرات في الجهاز
القضاء
الاسرائيلي لكن حاليا هذه المظاهرات تخرج
احتجاجا على اعلان رئيس الحكومه
اقاله وزير الدفاع
بعد اعلانه يوم امس عن مطالبته بوقف اجراء
هذه التغييرات في الجهاز القضائي
وتقليص صلاح المحكمه العليا وزير الدفاع
من حزب الليكود من الائتلاف الحاكم هو اول
وزير في هذه الحكومه يعلن بشكل صريح وعلني
عن معارضته لهذه التغييرات ولكن قرار
نتنياهو بفصله بعد نحو 24 ساعه من الصمت
كان خلالها نتنياه عمليا يجري اتصالات
واستشارات حول هذا الاعلان بالنسبه
عده مصادر في وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
تتحدث ان نتنياهو ردخ لضغوط من وزير
القضاء يا ريفلافين وهو صاحب رؤيه هذه
التغييرات في جهاز القضاء وايضا لابنه
يائير
نتنياهو الذي لطالما كان يفرض التدخلاته
في السياسه الاسرائيليه هناك مظاهرات
واسعه بالقرب من منزل نتنياهو في مدينه
القدس مدينه تل ابيب قباله مقر وزاره
الدفاع الاسرائيليه وحتى انه تم الاعلان
قبل قليل عن اغلاق الطريق الرئيسي الواصل
بين مدينه القدس وتل ابيب بفعل هذه
المظاهرات لم يعني للامانه انا لم اشهد
مثل حاله الغليان هذه في الشارع
ويبدو باننا
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي اذا سمحتي نجوان
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي تقول بان متظاهرين
يخترقون حواجز الشرطه ويتجهون نحو منزل
نتالياهو في القدس اشرحي لنا اكثر
التحول في مسار هذه التظاهرات وانت قلت في
البدايه بانها تحولت من احتجاجات مناهضه
للتعديلات القضائيه الان احتجاجات على
قرار نتنياهو اقاله وزير الدفاع ما الذي
يعني هذا ونحن تابعنا بالمناسبه صور
مباشره قبل قليل لهذه الاحتجاجات تفضل يا
نجوان باقتضاب لو سمحتي
بالفعل بالفعل ربما حاله الاحتجاجات
السلميه التي شهدها الشارع الاسرائيلي منذ
عده اسابيع تحولت حاليا الى احتجاجات
غاضبه جدا لان بالنسبه للمحتاجين قرار
نتنياهو يعني صب الزيت على النار في هذه
المرحله فقط لمجرد تجرا وزير الدفاع
مخالفه رؤيه نتنياهو والاجماع في حكومته
المتطرفه من قبل الاعضاء في الاحزاب
الدينيه الصهيونيه على هذه التغييرات
القضائيه والرضوخ ربما لتمر
بنغفيرتش المتطرفين في هذه الحكومه
وبالتالي تحولت هذه الاحتجاجات الى حاله
غضب ويوصف نتنياهو في الساعات الاخيره
بانه ديكتاتور خطير على دوله اسرائيل من
قبل اوصات مختلفه سياسيه وشعبيه رؤساء
الاحتجاجات ومنظمي هذه الاحتجاجات قالوا
بان نتنياهو هذه الليله اثبت مد خطورته
على مواصله الحكم في اسرائيل وهذا ايضا ما
سمعناه من عده مسؤولين سياسيين في اسرائيل
سواء كان من وزراء سابقين او مسؤولين
سياسيين ومسؤولين عسكريين قبل قليل فقط
صدر بيان مشترك عن رئيس المعارضه ورئيس
الحكومه الاسبق
بمشاركه وزير الدفاع الاسبق بنجاز يطالبوا
فيه كل الاعضاء في حزب الليكود عدم قبول
منصب او تولي منصب وزاره الدفاع وقالوا
بانه سيكون من العار عليهم قبول هذا
المنصب وايضا قالوا بان نتنياهو تجاوز كل
الخطوط الحمر هناك يوم غد سيعقد رئيس
نقابه العمال في اسرائيل اجتماعا
خاصا واستثنائيا وبحسب مصادر اعلاميه
اسرائيليه او وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه فانه
سيعلن عن اضراب شامل في كافه المرافق
الاقتصاديه والعماليه في اسرائيل احتجاجا
على هذا الاجراء بمعنى ان الخطوه التي
اتخذها نتنياهو تجر الى مزيد من
الاحتجاجات الى حاله من الغليان اكثر
فاكثر في الشارع الاسرائيلي التي تتحول
كما نشاهد الى حاله من الغضب الشديد ايذاء
تصرف نتنياهو واستفراده بالحكم كما يوصف
ابقى معك لان الصور تريدنا تباعا
بالمناسبه الصور التي نعرضها هي صور قبل
قليل من القدس وانت ذكرتي ان هناك ايضا
مظاهرات في تل ابيب واذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي قالت بان متظاهرين يخترقون
حواجز الشرطه ويتجهون نحو منزل نتنياهو في
القدس امام هذا الانقسام الحاصل نجوان ما
قدره الشرطه على احتواء الشارع في ظل هذا
الغليان سواء كان الاحتجاجات على قرارات
نتنياهو للتغيير القضائي او الان على
اقاله وزير الدفاع
نعم ستكون مهمه صعبه للغايه بالنسبه
للشرطه الاسرائيليه ضبط مثل هذه
الاحتجاجات في هذه المرحله لا سيما واننا
راينا قبل حتى هذه الخطوه باقاله وزير
الدفاع راينا بانه كانت هناك صدامات بين
الشرطه وبين المحتاجين لا سيما باعاز من
وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن كبير وهو وزير
الشرطه الحالي وزير الامن القومي كما اطلق
على نفسه وبالتالي
سيكون ربما من الصعب على عناصر الشرطه
والاعداد الكبيره التي افرزت لتامين هذه
المظاهرات بضبط الامور قبل قبل الاعلان عن
اقاله غالات كانت هناك مظاهرات تم التخطيط
لها قباله منازل اعضاء ونواب في الاحزاب
الحاكمه احزاب الائتلاف الحاكم ضمن
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه المتواصله ولكن حتى
خلال هذه المظاهرات التي كانت الاعداد بها
قليله لم تستطع الشرطه منع المتظاهرين من
النزول الى شوارع مركزيه في مدينه تل ابيب
احد الشوارع هو شارع ايلون والذي دائما
يقوم
اطلاق هذا الشارع وعندها تقوم الشرطه
بحمله اعتقالات في صفوف المتظاهرين بطلب
من وزير الامن القومي اتمار بن كبير عمليا
القيام بالاعتقالات وايضا عدم السماح
للمتظاهرين بالاحتجاج حاليا راينا هذه
الصور وهم يحاولون اقتحام الحواجز التي
احيطت في مقر اقامه رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو في الشق الغربي من مدينه القدس
بسبب حاله الغضب
القائمه حاليا جلال
اتركك لجمع مزيد من المعلومات حول هذه
التظاهرات في تل ابيب وفي القدس سنعود
اليك في ردود الفعل على اقاله وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يقف قلنت اعلن سلفه في المنصب
بني دعمه معتبرا ان نتنياهو يضع نفسه فوق
الامن واضاف بنيجانس ان اسرائيل تواجه
خطرا امنيا واضحا وملموسا بوضع نتنياهو
نفسه فوق الامن على عكس وزير الدفاع جلنت
الذي وضع امن اسرائيل اولويه على حساب
مصلحته اما زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
فقال ان اقاله غلنت خطوه جديده تمس الامن
القومي من حكومه معاديه للصهيونيه واصفا
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
بالخطر على امن دوله اسرائيل اما
المحتفلون بقرار الاقاله فكان اولهم وزير
الامن الداخلي اعتمار الذي كتب تغريده من
كلمتين قال فيها بدا الاصلاح
[موسيقى]
يظهر لنا من حيفا السيد الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي الاسرائيلي
هل بات الانشقاق في صفوف حزب نتنياهو
الليكود اكثر وضوحا الان
بكل تاكيد
اقاله جالنت اول خطوه بهذا الاتجاه كانت
هناك بوادر وعلامات اوليه بالاول يعني
عندما قال
من الليكود انه ضد الاستعجال في عمليه سن
هذه القوانين وبعد ذلك دافيد كمان عضم
عنصر مهم جدا في الكود ولكن الان الانشقاق
بات واضحا السؤال هل احنا فقط في الخطوه
الاولى من هذا الانشقاق ام
وسينتهي الامر في ذلك ام ان هناك الكثير
من الخطوات المزيد من الخطوات المزيد من
الشخصيات التي لا تقبل موقفنا اذا كان راس
هرم الجليد فقط حتى الان ما المتوقع اذا
ما الانعكاسات على حزب نتنياهو على
ائتلافه الحاكم وعلى بقائه في السلطه
في الساعات خاطئه جدا بالنسبه له سياسيا
وميدانيا ايضا نرى الصور التي تعطي من قدس
المتظاهرين يرفضون ما يحدث
في في البلاد يجتازون الجدران لكي يصلوا
الى بيت رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو بنفس الوقت
هم
يعني هناك اغلاق للشوارع في كلن حي البلاد
في حيفا في تل ابيب يقولون هذه ميدان
التحرير هم ينمون البقاء في الشارع
الرئيسي داخل تل ابيب
كل الليله ويقولون انها ميدان تحرير
اسرائيل هذا يعني انه نتنياهي نتنياهو في
وضع صعب جدا ما يحدث في الميدان يؤثر على
عذاب بارزين في الكود ولهذا السبب ويوم
الرد
بعد اقالته الى لجنه الامن والخارجيه في
الكنيسه التي يقودها ايدلجتين التي هو
كمان ضد المعارضه هدول العناصر مهمه
شخصيات مهمه في قياده اللكود ولهذا السبب
اعتقد ان هناك علامه سؤال كبيره جدا على
قدره نتنياه والتمريض هذه القوانين في
الكنيست هذا الاسبوع طيب هناك اجماع من
قبل المعارضه وحتى اطراف في الليكود كما
كما اسلفت على ان استمرار نتنياهو في
الحكم يشكل خطرا امنيا قوميا على على
اسرائيل اينما كان من هذا الخطر
لقيت قال هذا المساء انه اكبر تهديد على
امن اسرائيل هو نتنياهو المشكله انه
نتنياهو حاليا يقود هذه البلاد الى الى
الهاويه
والانشقاق هو موجود في كل اوساط المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ما نراه اليوم لم يسبق له مثيل
في كل تاريخ اسرائيل الان هناك ضغط على
شخصيات المرشحين لمنصب وزير الامن مثل
دفتر واخرين لمنعهم من قبول هذا المنزل
اعتقد انه هذه ازمه سياسيه كبيره جدا لا
اسمح لي سيدي اب في خبر عاجل نقلا عن
وسائل العلم الاسرائيليه قنصل اسرائيل في
نيويورك يعلن تقديم استقالته بعد اقاله
وزير الدفاع ولكن السؤال اليس من البديهي
ان يقيل رئيس حكومه وزير لا يلتزم سياسه
هذه الحكومه
فقط قال انه مع التفكير على ما يجري ليس
اكثر من ذلك ولكن المشكله انه نتنياهو
يطالب اخلاص كامل من كل وزرائه فبينما
الليكودا التي يقول عن نفسه انه من اكبر
الاحزاب الديمقراطيه في اسرائيل وانه مع
ديمقراطيه ضد الديكتاتوره هو يقل شخص وزير
الدفاع فقط لانه يقول ان ينتقد بلطف ما
يقوم به اعتقد انه هذا واضح جدا انه
نتنياهو يجب ان يصل الى نهايه حياته
السياسيه في هذه الخطوات والايام والساعات
القليله القادمه ستقول ذلك الساعه 11:00
في اسرائيل
والمتطهدين يخرجون الى شواربيل هذا لم
يحدث ابدا في تاريخ الكاتب والمحل السياسي
الاسرائيلي في حيفا شكرا لك
شكرا لكم
تطورات عديده اذا تتزامن مع تحذيرات
مستمره بداها رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي قبل
ايام بشان تاثير الازمه على جهوزيه
اسرائيل في التصدي للتطورات الامنيه فيما
تتصاعد اصوات تدق ناقوس الخطر من
تداعياتها على الداخل الاسرائيلي
تتسع الازمه السياسيه الداخليه في اسرائيل
وفي المقابل تضيق حلقاتها على رئيس
الوزراء بيمينه ياهو
فجبهه المعاردين لخطته للتعديلات القضائيه
التي بدات بالمعارضه ثم الجمعيات الحقوقيه
ثم الجيش واجهزه المخابرات وصلت الى
حكومته وزير الدفاع احد اقرب حلفاء
نتنياهو خرج ليعلن ان ما وصفه بالشقاق
الداخلي العميق خطر داهم وفي تحدي رسمي
للخط الحكومي دعا الى وقف التعديلات
القضائيه وتاجيلها الى ما بعد عيد الفصح
في مايوير المقبل
موقف جلنط لقى ترحيبا من المعارضه وجر
عليه غضب جناح اقصى اليمين في الحكومه حيث
طالب وزير الامن الداخلي لتمر بن كبير
نتنياهو باقاله وزير الدفاع وهو ما استجاب
له نتنياهو
ويتعمق الشرخ السياسي في اسرائيل بشكل حاد
لاول مره في تاريخها حيث يرفض اليسار
الاستسلام لما يرى انه رغبه اليمين
المتدين في التغول والسيطره على مفاصل
الدوله واختطاف القضاء من جهته يعتبر
اليمين الحاكم باغلبيه ضيقه ان نتائج
الانتخابات تحول له سن التشريعات كما يشاء
كما تحدث اليمين رغبه الافلات من قبضه
القضاء الجانح نحو اليسار معضله سياسيه
تفسر حديث الرئيس الاسرائيلي عن احتمال
انهيار الدوله ان لم يتم التوصل الى توافق
لكن الخيارات امام نتنياهو كلها سيئه فاما
ان تذيقه مراره سياسيه عبر تخلي الحلفاء
عنه ان هو قرر التراجع عن التعديلات واما
الملاحقه القضائيه ان سقطت حكومته ولم يعد
لرئاسه الوزراء هذا ان لم تنحو الامور
باتجاه مغامره عسكريه غير مضمونه مالاتها
في ظل الاستقطاب داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
والامنيه
[موسيقى]
من ام الفحم داخل الخط الاخضر دكتور مهند
مصطفى مدير مركز مدى الكرمل للدراسات
الاجتماعيه التطبيقيه والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي دكتور مصطفى الينا يتجه
نتنياهو مع هذه الازمه التي تعصف بحكومته
وبحزبه
بالسياسه وبالشارع ايضا
اثبت اليوم وايضا في خطاب يوم الخميس انه
مستمر في التغيرات الدستوريه لا شيء يودعه
وزير الدفاع جلنت هو لم يكن موقفه معارض
للتغييرات الدستوريه ما قالوا في خطابه ان
هذه التعديلات الدستوريه تهدد تماسك الجيش
الاسرائيلي واجب وقفها ولكن اقاله جلند هي
كانت ايضا رساله من نتنياهو الى كل اعضاء
اللكود انه مستمر وانه لن يقبل اي معارضه
لهذا التغييرات الدستوريه واضح ان نتنياهو
في مازق شخصي في مازق سياسي ويعتقد ان
الخروج من هذا المازك يكون من خلال
الاستمرار دون الالتفاء جانبا نحو هذه
التغييرات الدستوريه هذه رغبته وهذه ايضا
رغبه حلفائه في الحكومه لذلك هو مستمر حتى
النهائي هو يعني حتى قال بانه سيواجه ما
سماه العصيان العسكري كيف تعتقد او ما هي
ادوات نتنياهو لمواجهه ما سماه العصيان
العسكري
نعم يعني سبب خطابه بالامس وكان رفض
الخدمه في الجيش بالذات من الاحتياط من
ضباط الاحتياط وبالذات من ضباط الاحتياط
من الوحدات العليا النبويه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ولذلك قالت وكانه في خطا لهذا
الرافد لهذا العصيان في الجيش وهو يريد
وزير الدفاع الذي يتصدى لهذا الرفض طبعا
هذا الامر سيكون معاكس تماما لانه اقاله
سوف تعزز من العصيان في الجيش من رفض
الخدمه في داخل جيش بالذات من ضباط
الاحتياط ولذلك اي وزير الدفاع سوف ياتي
بعد سوف يواجه مشكله اكبر مما واجهها لانه
الان هؤلاء الضباط الذين رفضوا المثول
للجيش في الاحتياط سوف يكون لهم اكثر
مشروعيه واكثر ادعاءات من اجل الاستماره
في هذا العصيان طيب المخاوف على الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي بحسب شخصيات سياسيه
معارضه لبنيامين نتنياهو ما هي التداعيات
المحتمله لهذا الشرخ في صفوف الائتلاف
ائتلاف الحاكم على الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي بتقديرك
نعم هنالك يعني عده تداعيات اولا نهايه
نهايه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي هو جيش الشعب
دخول هذا النقاش وهذا الانقسام الى داخل
جيش الاسرائيلي يهدد تماسك الجيش
الاسرائيلي وجهوزيته الجيش الاسرائيلي لم
يكن فقط جيش عسكري وكان جيش اجتماعي معنى
انه الجيش الذي وحد المجتمع المهاجرين في
اسرائيل اسرائيل من فئات مختلفه المكان
الوحيد الذي بقي في اسرائيل الذي يوحد هذا
المجتمع هو كان الجيش دخول هذا الانقسام
اذا الجيش ويهدد الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
بمعنى ان يهدد من شرعيه الجيش الان هنالك
في هجوم على الجيش وذلك في دفاع عن الجيش
هذا لم يكن له اي مثيل في تاريخ اسرائيل
بالاضافه الى ذلك على المستوى التنفيذي
هنالك ضباط مئات الضباط هناك في حوالي 200
طيار في الجيش الاسرائيلي يرفضون الذهاب
الى التدريبات الان
وطيارين الاحتياط هم طيارين تنفيذيين معنى
ان سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي يعتمد بالاساس
على الجيش الاحتياط عدم تواجد هؤلاء
الطيارين الى
لا يعني هذه الدول الان سيكون لها اكثر
مشروعيه من اجل عدم التعاون مع اسرائيل
يعني حتى قبل هذه التهيؤات الدستوريه كان
هناك في موقف دولي بعدم التعامل مع وزراء
في داخل اسرائيل
يعني راينا ان سبورتج سافر الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والى فرنسا ولم يتم
استقباله من اي مسؤول رسمي في داخل
الدولتين الان هنالك اكثر مقاطعه الان
اسرائيل هي اكثر عزله سياسيه في تاريخه عن
المستوى الدولي بعد حرب 73 ولذلك هذا سوف
يؤثر على العلاقات السئيل مع الدول
الخارجيه يعني فقط الملاحظه حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يدعي نتنياهو الى زياره
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهذا الامر
غير مسبوق في اسرائيل وهذا يدل على عزله
اسرائيل صحيح انه هنالك في مصالح سياسيه
واستراتيجيه مشتركه بين اسرائيل وبين دول
اخرى ولكن هذه الدول على الاقل على مستوى
الراي العام على مستوى الاعلام على مستوى
النخب الاكاديميه والادبيه موضوع القيم
المشتركه هي وموضوع مهم في علاقه مع
اسرائيل تراجع اسرائيل عن هذه القيم مثل
القيم الديمقراطيه مثل استقلاليه القضاء
سوف يؤدي بالنهايه الى انعزال اسرائيل
اكثر وليس فقط على المستوى السياسي
المستوى الشعبي في هذه الدول ويؤكد ان
اسرائيل متجهه نحو ان تكون دوله فيها
النظام الديمقراطي معطوب بشكل عميق وايضا
دوله اللي فيها الحريات والديمقراطيه
معدومه ليس فقط اتجاه اليهود وايضا اتجاه
الفلسطينيين القناه الثانيه عشر
الاسرائيليه تقول باننت يبحث تقديم
استئناف امام المحكمه العليا ضد اقالته
تحدثت عن العصيان العسكري دكتور
وخطورته على
المخطط الامني لاسرائيل اسرائيل اسرائيل
تقول بانها تواجه ما تصفه الارهاب كيف
تعتقد بان هذا الشرخ والعصيان العسكري
سينعكس على هذا الجانب تحديدا وعلى ما
يفكر فيه نتنياهو وحكومته في الشق الامني
يعني دعني اقول انه يعني حاليا الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يقوم بعمليات العسكريه
مثلا في الضفه الغربيه الان التاثير هذا
العصيان هو تاثير على المستوى البعيد على
المستوى الاستراتيجي وليس عن المستوى
القصير بمعنى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما زال
يمارس اعماله في الضفه الغربيه ولكن عن
المستوى الاستراتيجي وهذا هو الخطر
الاساسي عندما تحدثون في اسرائيل لانه
هنالك في تهديد عن الامن القومي المقصود
هو تهديد مكانه الجيش كجيش الشعب هذا
سيكون له تداعيات استراتيجيه على المدى
البعيد لانه كل الطبقه النخبويه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالذات في السلاح الجو في
السايبر في الاستخبارات العسكريه في
الوحدات التكنولوجيه هؤلاء كلهم معارضون
للتغييرات الدستوريه هؤلاء على المدى
البعيد اذا هذه الحكومه اقرت هذه
التغييرات بشكل نهائي وسائل انتقلت الى
عهد سياسي جديد هؤلاء لن يخدمونا في الجيش
هذا سوف يؤدي الى تراجع مكانه الجيش الى
تراجع جهزيته ولا تراجع كفاءته هذا سيكون
له على المستوى الاستراتيجي على جهزيه هذا
الجيش في تحدي التحديات الاستراتيجيه
سيكون له تاثير كبير جدا على الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالنهايه الذي يمسك بالجيش على
المستوى الوحدات المركزيه والاساسيه
والنخباويه هم من شرائح اجتماعيه في داخل
مجتمع الاسرائيلي معارضه للتغييرات
الدستوريه اذا قرروا هؤلاء عدم الالتزام
والعصيان بشكل نهائي من الجيش فان الجيش
الاسرائيليا بين الشرائح الاجتماعيه بين
مؤيد ومعارض ولكن ايضا قوه الجيش فاس حربه
الجيش الاسرائيلي سوف يعني يصيبها الضرر
والعطب بشكل الذي يمنع الجيش من الاستعداد
لتحديات استراتيجيه على سبيل المثال على
مستوى التحضير ضرب عسكريه لمشروع النووي
الايراني التحضير ضرب عسكريه لهذا المشروع
يعتمد بالاساس على الضباط الذين الان
يتمردون في داخل الجيش الاسرائيلي
يعتمد بالاساس تبقى معنا كنا نتحدث طبعا
عن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والبيت
الابيض في اول تعليق يقول ما يجري في
اسرائيل سيكون له انعكاسات على جوزيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي وهذا ما تحدثنا به دكتور
مهند مصطفى نشرك معنا في النقاش في رام
الله السيد هاني المصري مدير مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
سيد هاني كيف تراقبون ما يحصل الان مع
نتنياهو هذا الشرخ السياسي العصيان
العسكري والاحتجاجات
المتواتره في الشارع
ما يجري في اسرائيل ازمه عميقه غير مسبوقه
تهدد يعني مستقبل اسرائيل وهي نتيجه
للاستعمار الاستيطاني والاحتلال والفصل
العنصري واستخدام العنف والقوه بحل
المشاكل خاصه مع الفلسطينيين هم اعتقدوا
ان هذا سيكون محصورا بالفلسطينيين ولكنهم
الان يفاجئوا بان هذه الطرق في العمل تصل
اليهم وبالتالي هناك انقسام غير مسبوق في
اسرائيل وعندما نتحدث عن ما يجري في الجيش
الاسرائيلي علينا ان نتذكر ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي له دوله وليس مثل بقيه الدول
الدوله لها جيش فبالتالي مكانه الجيش مثل
البقره المقدسه عندما يكون هناك انقسام
كبير يصل حتى الى داخل الجيش كما نعرف
بالانتخابات الاخيره واحد من خمسه من
المنتخبين من الجيش الصهيونيه الدينيه
وهناك استطلاعات اشارت الى ان 40% من
الضباط
لابد من الاشاره الى العواجل وهي متواتره
وسريعه قنصل اسرائيل في نيويورك كنا
تحدثنا بانه قدم استقالته قبل قليل يقول
لم يعد بامكاني الاستمرار في تمثيل هذه
الحكومه هذه سابقه في تاريخ الحكومات
الاسرائيليه عصيان عسكري الان قنصل
اسرائيل في نيويورك يقول بانه لم يعد
بامكانه الاستمرار في تمثيل هذه الحكومه
ما دلالات كل هذا سيد هاني
هذا يعني ان اسرائيل في مرحله يعني انقسام
هذا الانقسام يمكن ان يؤدي الى مواجهه
يعني مثلما قال يعني رئيس الشباك السابق
اذا اقرت الحكومه الاصلاحات القضائيه التي
تريدها ورفضت محكمه العدل العليا هذه يعني
الاصلاحات يمكن ان يكون هناك تعدد في
الولاء من
يوالي الحكومه ومن سيوالي محكمه العدل
العليا وهذا سيعني امكانيات للصدام طبعا
من المبكر القول ان هذا سيؤدي الى حرب
اهليه كما توقع البعض ولكن هذا سيعني تصدع
كبير في موقع ومكانه اسرائيل وموقع الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما اشكال هذا الصدام سيد هاني
ما اشكال هذا الصدام
ممكن يكون اشكال اولا صدام في الشارع شارع
مقابل شارع ممكن يتحول ايضا الى صدام في
داخل الجيش بين من يؤيد الاصلاحات ومن
يعارضها نحن في الضفه المحتله نلاحظ
الانقسام داخل الجيش بشكل جلي اكثر من اي
مكان اخر هناك ضباط اعلنوا منذ يعني تشكيل
الحكومه وهددوا الفلسطينيين
ومارسوا ورفعتهم
لدموع المتطرفين المستوطنين على الاكتاف
وهم ساهموا معهم في محرقه حواره ويقومون
بتوفير الحمايه لكل الاعمال العدائيه التي
تجري ضد الفلسطينيين الانقسام يمكن ان
يؤدي الى صدام عنيف وبالتالي طبعا هناك
عوامل ستدفع يعني
لوقف هذه المساله لا تصل الى النهايه لان
هناك اطراف خارجيه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لن تبقى متفرجه الى على ما يجري
في اسرائيل ستبذل كل جهودها لحمايه
اسرائيل من نفسها لان الخلاف هو مع
الحكومه سيد هاني هذا ينطبق على من اشكال
هذا الصدام الان الشرطه الاسرائيليه تشتبك
مع محتجين يحاولون الوصول الى منزل
بنيامين نتنياهو بالقدس ونحن نتابع هذه
الصور بعضها مباشر من القدس وتل ابيب وقبل
قليل ايضا نتابع الصور من القدس للخيال
التي تحاول تفريق هذه التظاهرا لاحظ ايضا
بالصور المباشره المحتجين يرقصون بالاعلام
الاسرائيليه في القدس وهذا التجمع الكبير
في تل ابيب مظاهرات ليست فقط في تل ابيب
وانما ايضا في حيفا والقدس ضد قرار رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
اقاله وزير الدفاع اذا نتابع هذه الصور
التي تاتينا من القدس ومن تل ابيب اضافه
الى تظاهرات وفدنا بها في حيفا نجوان سمري
عبر الهاتف تنضم الينا لتطلعنا على اخر
هذه التطورات وهذه الاحتجاجات التي تتوسع
نجوان في تل ابيب وحيفا والقدس وتحديدا
ايضا امام منزل رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو هذا الاشتباك بين الشرطه التي
تستخدم خراطيم المياه لتفريق المتظاهرين
امام منزل نتنياهو نجوان
نعم بالفعل جلال دعني فقط اشير انني في
الطريق من القدس الى تل ابيب وبدانا يعني
مشهد ازمه مروريه خانقه في الشارع الرئيسي
الواصل بين مدينه القدس ومدينه تل ابيب
هذا الشارع الذي يطلق عليه شارع رقم واحد
هو احد الشوارع الرئيسيه
المركزيه الذي يصل بين تل ابيب وعده فقد
جميل تل ابيبولا الى مدينه القدس يبدو
بانه مغلق بفعل المظاهرات والاحتجاجات
التي خرجت بشكل تلقائي في مدن مختلفه الى
محاور بطرق عده يتم اغلاق محاور طرق عده
رئيسيه شارع ايضا رئيسي في مدينه تل ابيب
مغلق ايضا وهو شارع ايلون يغلق في بعض
الاحيان ويتم بعد تفريق الشرطه للمتظاهرين
حاله من الغليان في مواقع عده قبل قليل
من الشرطه الاسرائيليه قمع المستجين قباله
من منزل رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في
الشق الغربي من القدس المدينه
بعد ان اقدم عدد منهم على اتهام الحواجز
التي اقلتها الشرطه في محيط منزل نتنياهو
وحاولوا
وحاولوا الوصول الى المنزل حاليا بعد
الاخبار العاجله جلال بان مصدر سياسي في
حزب النقود الحاكم في اول تصريح لاحد
اعضاء حزب اللي كود بعد اطاله
جالنت وزير الدفاع عفوا
بان نتنياهو فقد السيطره بن كامل هذا نقلا
عن القناه الاسرائيليه 12 اذا مسؤول سياسي
في حزب قال لي حاكم حزن بنيامين نتنياهو
يكون في اعصاب
اقاله وزير الدفاع وهذه الاحتجاجات التي
خرجت بشكل عشوائي وتلقائي للاحتجاج على
هذا القرار بان
نتنياهو فقد السيطره
بالكامل اذا الشارع الاسرائيلي في حاله
غليان
والمظاهرات خرجت بشكل عشوائي وتلقائي غير
تلك المظاهرات التي تم تنظيمها في وقت
السابق هذا هذا اليوم قباله
المتواصله منذ بدايه هذا العام ضد
التغييرات التي
بداتها في الجهاز قضائي بهدف ما يكونونه
اضعاف
اسرائيل وتخليص صلاحيات كما الاسرائيليه
العليا يوم امس خلال الليله المرض صنعنا
الدفاع طبعا ستبقي معنا نجوان سنعود اليك
لاحقا اعود واذكر باننا نتابع هذه الصور
المباشره من القدس وتل ابيب وايضا صور قبل
قليل من القدس ونشير الى انه بحسب وسائل
الاعلام اسرائيليه فان الجامعات تعلن
تعليق الدراسه اعتبارا من الغد حتى اشعار
اخر نشرك معنا في هذه التغطيه من غزه
الدكتور صالح النعامي الباحث المختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه
سيد صالح كيف تتابع الفصائل الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه وتنظر الى ازمه نتنياهو الحاضره
امامنا في هذه المشاهد والمظاهرات شعبيا
وسياسيا في كل جوانبها خاصه ما يتعلق
بالعصيان العسكري
[تصفيق]
واضح تماما ان هناك حاله من الترقد لانه
يحدث في الساحه الاسرائيليه
ان هناك يعني تخطيط يكاد يكون دام لدى
القيادات الاسرائيليه دائما تحاول ان تنقل
مركز الاهتمام من
الاوائلنا
عندما تكون الحاكمه تحاول نقل هذا الى
ساحات خارجيه وهذا حدث اكثر من مره تحديدا
الان فيما يتعلق بالوضع الاسرائيلي داخل
واضح تماما انه قالت وزير الحرب
جاءك خطوه اتفاقيه من قبل بنيامين يدرك
يعي تماما ان هناك ايضا قيادات في حزب
النقود يعني عقد عبر بشكل واضح وصريح عن
تحفظها واعتراضها على بحديثك عن حزب الكود
السيد النعامي القناه الثانيه عشر
الاسرائيليه تنقل عن مسؤول كبير في حزب
الليكود بان نتنياهو فقد السيطره ما الذي
يعني هذا ان يخرج هكذا تصريح من مسؤول
كبير في حزب الليكود تنقله القناه الثانيه
عشر الاسرائيليه
يعني
يعني انا قلت له
هذا المسؤول قد يكون احد اربعه قيادات وهم
الوزير نير بركات وزير
اما احد رئيس الداخليه في الكنيسه
ووزير الرئيس الخارجيه والامن
والرابع اللي هو طبعا اليوم تم قالته هذه
القيادات في داخل الوقود عبرت الايام
الاخيره بشكل واضح وصريح عن اعتراضها
وتحفظها على الاصلاحات القضائيه
بالنسبه
شخصيه مهمه جدا
يعني طالب بوقف هذه الاصلاحات وبالتالي
قالت مبادره
تاتي خطوه لمنع الاخرين من ان يقدموا على
الخطوه التي اقدم عليها دكتور صالح اعود
اليك دكتور صالح النعامي الباحث مختص في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه السيد هاني البيت
الابيض قال بان ما يحصل الان
يؤثر على جهوزيه الجيش الاسرائيلي كيف
تفهم هذا التصريح من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الداعم الكبير لاسرائيل
اعتقد ان هذا التصريحي يعبر عن مدى القلق
الذي تعيشه الاداره الامريكيه على ما يجري
في اسرائيل خاصه في وسط المخاطر الكبيره
الناجمه عن امكانيه حصول ايران على
القنبله النوويه بالتالي اسرائيل الان لا
يمكن ان تشكل اي ردع لايران هي ليست في
حاله تستطيع فيها ان تشن الحرب على ايران
هذا الامر حتى في السابق كان صعبا الان
اعتقد اصبح اكثر صعوبه ان لم يكن مستحيلا
بالتالي الاداره الامريكيه تخشى كثيرا
خاصه ان هناك في تراجع بالدوري الامريكي
بالكامل بالمنطقه وهناك تقدم للصين
ولروسيا وتغير في المعادلات الاقليميه كما
لاحظنا باتفاق بكين بين السعوديه وايران
اذا الوضع كله لم يعد كما كان في السابق
صحيح انه لم يتغير تغيرا كاملا ولكن هذه
بوادر للتغير الذي يمكن ان يحدث في
المستقبل ومكانه اسرائيل في المنطقه مهمه
جدا للاستراتيجيه الامريكيه وعندما تصبح
اسرائيل غير قادره على القيام بوظيفتها
المعهوده هذا يضر بالمصالح الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه لذلك هناك قلق شديد في الاداره
الامريكيه على الجيش وعلى جهزيه اسرائيل
وعلى قدرتها وعلى بقائها وهذا امر يحدث
لاول مره طيب دكتور مهند مصطفى
اشير الى ان ايضا
في خبر عاجل ورده قبل قليل اعضاء
فالائتلاف الحكومي يقولون نحن في صدمه
ورئيس الوزراء اخطا ايضا هذا خبر تنقله
القناه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه عن اعضاء
الائتلاف الحكومي نحن في صدمه ورئيس
الوزراء اخطاء هل هي بوادر انصراط ائتلاف
حكومه نتنياهو دكتور مهند مصطفى
يعني حاليا لا ولكن يعني ما حدث الان ممكن
يدعف نتنياهو في داخل حكومته وبالذات في
الداخل اللي كود نتنياهو هو كان يعني
الرجل المهيمن على الكود حوالي عشرين سنه
ما يحدث الان هو يدرك نتنياه هو ذلك ممكن
يعني تخرج اصوات تبدا بالتمرد عليه هذا
التمرد قد يكون حاليا مثلا في عدم التصويت
على التشريعات القانونيه ولكن
مع ذلك مع ذلك يعني هذه الاصوات هي ما
زالت يعني اصوات مش انها معارضه للتغيرات
الدستوريه يعني على المستوى الشخصي وليس
انسان ديموقراطي يعني هو لم يعارض
التغييرات الدستوريه من الناحيه المبدئيه
او من الناحيه الديمقراطيه هو عرضها لانه
راى بام عينه وعن قرب ما يحصل في الجيش
الاسرائيلي
والتهديدات الامنيه التي تحدث في داخل
جراء هذه التغيرات الدستوريه ولذلك هو طلب
وقف هذه التغييرات الدستوريه
الليكود بدا يلاحظ ان نتنياهو بدا يضعف
وبالذات على ضوء هذا الاحتجاج المستمر منذ
اكثر من 13 اسبوع يعني هذا امر حقيقه يعني
غير مسبوق في التاريخ الاسرائيلي هنالك في
احتجاج مثابر جدا جدا وهذا الاحتجاج يعني
فيه اندماج لنخب اقتصاديه نخب عسكريه
اجتماعيه ادبيه فنيه وايضا سياسيه والطبقه
الوسطى الاسرائيليه عمليا هذا الاحتجاج هو
احتجاج المركز الاسرائيلي الذي يحمل دوله
اسرائيل في كل الجوانب هذا الامر بدا يدعف
نتنياهو اضعاف نتنياهو في داخل الكود سوف
يؤدي الى صعود خصومه في الداخل سوف
يتشجعون اكثر من اجل ان يسمعوا صوتهم ضد
تنياهو من اجل على الاقل انه يوقف هذا
التيارات الدستوريه على على المدى القريب
من اجل التحاور الان لاحظ انه هذا
الاحتجاج الان الصاقب في اسرائيل هو نابع
للاساس نابع بالاساس انه نتنياهو مره بعد
مره يعني يتحدى الجمهور الاسرائيلي يعني
عندما خطب اسم دوله وطرح تسويه نتنياهو
عرضها يوم الخميس نتنياهو عمليا خلف
القانون الاسرائيلي قال الان انا سوف
اشارك واكون شريك في التيارات الدستوريه
وخالف قرار المستشار القضائيه للحكومي
والان هو اقال جلنت وبذلك هو عمليا نتنياه
يقوم بتحدي المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعني هو
يعني في كل مفصل من مفاصل هذا الاحتجاج
منذ نشوء الحكومه حتى الان نتنياهو لا
يتراجع فقط يتحدى الجمهور الاسرائيلي كلما
تحدى الجمهور الاسرائيلي هذا الجمهور هذا
الجمهور يقوم باحتجاج ربما دكتور
يقول بانه فقد السيطره هل ما زال بامكان
نتنياهو ان يستعيد هذه السيطره بتقديرك
لا لا هو فقد السيطره تماما ولكن فقد
السيطره بمفهوم انه نتنياهو الذكي المحنك
الذي يفهم الشارع الذي يفهم كيف يراوغ فقد
نتنياهو يعني
الان
الموجود في مازق فقد نتنياهو المحنك كما
كان في الماضي هذا المفهوم المفقد السيطره
بمعنى لم يعد يستطيع ان يفرق ما هي
القرارات الصحيحه والصائبه وما هي
القراءات الخاطئه هذا فقدان للسيطره يعني
كان يستطيع منذ اسبوعين ان ياخذ
اقتراح رئيس الدوله رئيس الدوله اقترح
اقتراح للتسويه بمعنى تعالوا وتفاوضوا على
هذا المقترح فكانت هنالك فرصه نتنياهو ان
يقبل هذا المقترح وان ينهي هذا الاحتجاج
وان يزني عن الشجره ولكن نتنياه رفضه هذا
مفهوم ان نتنياهو فقد السيطره بمعنى
نتنياهو لم الان غير قادر طيب ان يحدد ما
هو صائب للوقود بهذا المفهوم هو يشكل خطر
على ذاته وعلى الحكومه
وعلى اسرائيل سيد هاني انطلاقا من ما قاله
اعضاء في الائتلاف الحكومي بانهم في صبه
كبيره وبان رئيس الوزراء ارتكب خطا
استراتيجيا ما الرساله التي يريد هؤلاء
الاعضاء في الائتلاف الحكومي لتتنياهو
ارسالها الى نتنياهو في هذه المرحله
هم يشعرون ان سفينه الحكومه تتجه نحو
الغرق ويحاولون يعني لوم نتنياهو على هذا
المصير خاصه انه فقد قدرته يعني على
السيطره ولا يعرف ماذا يفعل بالضبط اذا
استمر في الاصلاحات القضائيه هذا سيؤدي
الى تشقق اضافي في صفوف الليكود اذا لم
يقم بذلك هناك من هدد بالقاده اللكود
بانهم سيرفضون وبالتالي سيتمردون على
الليكود يعني في كل الاحوال في وضع صعب
للغايه يعني وبالتالي هو الان تقوده
الاحداث اكثر ما هو يقودها في السابق كان
يسمى الساحر الان انقلب السحر عليه ولا
يعرف ماذا يفعل كان عليه ان يتراجع منذ
فتره مبكره الان حتى التراجع لم يعد ينقذ
يمكن انقاذه وهذا امر نراه بشكل واضح وم
وكلما تمر الساعات وليس الايام بدون البحث
عن مخرج نلاحظ مصير نتنياهو وهذا طبعا
يستحق هذا المصير لما ارتكبه من فضائح
وجرائم
غلب به مصالحه الفرديه على مصالح حزبه
ودولته
وكل شيء المشهد على الارض يتطور وهو
متسارع كما نتابع مظاهرات في حيفا في
القدس في اكثر من مكان وايضا في تل ابيب
اعود اليك نجوان سمري لاحظنا في الصور
الخياله كانت تحاول ان تفرق
المتظاهرين في القدس اعتقد انها امام منزل
نتنياهو وتابعنا الاخبار العاجله ايضا
التي تقول عن اشتباك بين المتظاهرين وقوات
الامن الاسرائيليه كيف تتعاطى قوه الامن
مع المتظاهرين بحسب معلوماتك حتى الان مع
هذه التظاهرات نتابع هنا في الصور يبدو ان
هناك مصابه على الارض
واعتقال احد الشبان هذه الصور مباشره من
القدس اذا اقطياد شابه من المتظاهرين
والمتظاهرات اذا رجال الامن يلجاون الى
العنف مع المتظاهرين لابعادهم عن هذه
النقطه التي اعتقد بانها مكان او منزل
بنيامين التنياهو نجوان تفيدين اكثر عن
هذه المعلومات تفضلي
نعم بالفعل لهذه المواجهات وتوصف
بالمواجهات العنيفه في الاعلام الاسرائيلي
في محيط
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الواقع في الشرق
الغربي بمدينه القدس مع الاعلان عن اطاله
بدا المئات من المستشير في التوافر الى
هذه المنطقه
والتظاهر وكانت هناك محاولات من قبل عدد
من المحتاجين باقتحام حواجز الشرطه التي
اقامتها الشرطه في محيط منزل نتنياهو
وعائلته ولكن
عفوا
عائلته لكن الشرطه تحاول حتى هذه اللحظه
استخدام كل الرسائل والطرق في محاوله لطب
المتظاهرين ومنعهم من الوصول الى او
بالاقتراب منزل نتنياهو على نحو
اقرب مما هم عليه ولكن من الواضح بان
الشرطه بدات تلتجا الى الوسائل فض
المحتاجين من خلال ريشه البيئه مياه وايضا
ربما
[تصفيق]
نشاهد في هذه من تلك المنطقه حاله الغضب
هذه تتكرر في عده مدن داخل الخط الاخضر في
مدينه حيفا خرج المئات ايضا قبل قليل في
مظاهره بدات في عده شوارع نحن حاليا في
الطريق من مدينه القدس باتجاه تل ابيب
وشهيدنا في الطريق عده تظاهرات عشوائيه
خرجت وقامت باغلاق هذا الشارع الرئيسي في
شارع رقم واحد الذي يرسل بين تل ابيب
والخيط وعندك مدن في جنوب مدينه تل ابيب
ايضا مظاهرات واحتجاجات ومزاد عشوائيه
تخرج باعداد كبيره في مناطق مختلفه هذا
بالاضافه الى ردود فعل متتاليه من
مسؤولينا اسرائيليين ومن
[موسيقى]
سيارته رسميه وشعبيه وقياديه ايضا على
مستويات عده لاي نوع ان هناك
لعشرون السياسيه
المعرفين في اسرائيل اعلن في الساعات
الاخيره عن انضمامه الى مجموعه الجنود ممن
سيقومون بعصيان اوامر الاوامر
وعدم الامتثال الى قزازات الاحتياط عندما
يستدعى الى الخدمه هناك العام في نيويورك
الجنسيه الاسرائيلي في نيويورك اعلنت قبل
قليل ايضا عن تقديمي استقالته استقالته
هناك العديد من المسؤولين الذين يكون
بتصريحات لرسائل اعلام اسرائيليه حتى من
داخل حزب الليكود بان هناك حاله من فقدان
السيطره في اسرائيل بالكامل عما يحدث في
الشارع بان نتنياهو فقد السيطره هناك من
يصرف قراره باطاله وزير الدفاع بانه خطا
استراتيجي كبير ونحن نتحدث عن اشخاص من
جانبه من طرفه لا نتحدث
بانه تجاوز كل الخطوط الحمر وبانه اثبت
هذه الليله بانه ديكتاتور كبير بالمناسبه
هناك ايضا اضرابات اعلنت اضرب سيبدا في
كافه المؤسسات الاكاديميه والجامعات
الاسرائيليه الى جانب
اعلام متوقع في مؤتمر صحفي سيعقده رئيس
نقابه العمال العامه في اسرائيل عن اضراب
مفتوح ايضا لكافه ارافق العماليه
والاقتصاديه في اسرائيل بدءا من يوم غد
وهذا يعني ان هذه الاحتجاجات تتسع تاخذ
منحا اخر
ومن المتوقع ان تجر احتجاجات في قطاعات
اخرى الاطباء رجال الاعمال رجال الهايتك
او من يعملون في هذا القتال وربما ايضا قد
يجر وربما خ
ايضا الى معادين اخرين من
الاعلان ربما
انتقالات
اقاله اليوم انت عندما اعط ما يقابلها عن
موظفه وطالبه هذه التشريعات التي احدثت في
هذه الاحتجاج جات باعتبار انها
تتقود جهاز الفضاء تزعجه وتتخلص منه
المحكمه العليا يعني راينا بان هناك
في حزب اللي يفوز دعم ولكن هؤلاء اليوم
تراجع احدهم في اعصاب تسريب بعض الانباء
بانه سيتولى هو منطقي وزير
عن وزير الزراعه في التطورات المتواتره
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي عن احد قاده
الاحتجاجات يقول ان اغلاق الطرق مستمر حتى
استقاله بنيامين نتنياهو اذا المطلب الان
تحول اكثر فاكثر الى استقاله نتنياهو
سنعود اليك نجوان سبري ولكن تابعنا قبل
قليل الموقف الاول من البيت الابيض بعد
اقاله نتنياهو وزير الدفاع البيت الابيض
قال انما يحصل في اسرائيل يؤثر على جهوزيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي محمد العلمي ينضم الينا
في واشنطن محمد اطلعنا على سياق هذا
التصريح
وما مكامل القلق بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فيما يحصل في اسرائيل على الارض
وجلال الولايات المتحده حكومه الرئيس
بايدن تحديدا تتابع هذه التطورات بقلق
كبير منذ بدايتها تقريبا
منذ ان كشف النقاب عن مشروع القانون
الجديد
لتضييق الخناقه على قضاه المحكمه العليا
وفريقهم في اسرائيل بحكم ان الديمقراطيين
تاريخيا وتحديدا
يركزون اكثر على حقوق الانسان
والديمقراطيه ربما من زملائه الجمهوريه
على الاقل
سمعنا لاجيال كيف سيتحدث
الاسرائيليون والعمليون عن قيم
الديمقراطيه المشتركه وان اسرائيل
يقول نؤكد على الحاجه الملحه للتوصل الى
حل وسط في اسرائيل هذا يدفعنا الى سؤال ما
هي رؤيه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لحل
هذا الانشقاق الحاصل في السياسه
الاسرائيليه
عمليا ليس لها رؤيه واضحه ولا حتى غامضه
بسبب حساسيه الموضوع
وايضا الاعتبارات السياسيه الداخليه
للموضوع ايضا
بالالوان المتحده لا يمكن ان تحل يعني او
تحاول الحد داخليه في اسرائيل غيرها لكن
الحكومه الامريكيه خاصه هذه الحكومه التي
لا تقيد ولدت كثيرا في رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين
منذ
محمد محمد العلمي شكرا لك القناه الثانيه
عشر الاسرائيليه تقول بان نتنياهو يجري
مشاورات الان في مكتبه اذن هذه التغطيه
مستمره معكم ونتابع هذه الصور من القدس من
محيط منزل نتنياهو من تل ابيب من حيفا قبل
قليل ومن القدس قبل قليل وعوده واذكر بان
القناه الثانيه عشر الاسرائيليه تقول بان
نتنياهو يجري مشاورات الان في مكتبه
التغطيه مستمره سلمى الج مل تتابع معكم
الان سلمى